قال الدفاع المدني في جنوب لبنان ان مدنيا
سشد وجرح مدنيان اخران في غاره اسرائيليه
استهدفت منزلا في بلده الخيام وافاد
مراسلنا بتعرض بلده الخيام
ومحيطها لخمس غارات اسرائيليه كما قصفت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه منزلا في بلده بني
حيان ما ادى الى تدميره وصدفت الغارات
ايضا محطه توزيع مياه عند نبع الوزاني كما
تعرض محيط بلدات حدوديه عده في جنوب لبنان
لقصف مدفعي اسرائيلي من ته اعلن حزب الله
انه او ان موقع زبدين الاسرائيلي وتجمع
للجنود في محيطه تم استهدافهما بمزارع
شبعه المحتله واكد الحزب استهداف
التجهيزات الفنيه في موقع راميا
الاسرائيلي قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
طائراته الحربيه هاجمت منشاه عسكريه تابعه
لحزب الله في منطقه مروحين جنوب لبنان
واضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان صحفي ان
بنا تحتيه عسكريه تابعه لحزب الله في قريه
بني حيان عرضت لقصف جوي اسرائيلي كما اشار
الى تعرض منطقتي مزارع شبعه وشوله في اصبع
الجليل لاطلاق صواريخ من
لبنان معنا في المتابعه من ابل السقي في
جنوب لبنان مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي
كما ينضم الينا من الجليل الاعلى مراسل
الجزيره حسن حسان مسعود اهلا بكم ابدا مع
ايهاب واخر التطورات
الميدانيه
نعم قبل قليل اعلن حزب الله عن مهاجمه ما
يعرف بمربى مدفعيه خربه ماعر وهو مربض
مدفعيه متقدم للجيش
الاسرائيلي يقصف مناطق مختلفه من القطاعين
الاوسط والغربي واستهدافه حزب الله بصاروخ
متفجر يطلق عليه اسم فلق واحد وهو ايراني
الصنع يحمل نحو 50 كيلوغراما من من
المتفجرات اطلقه باتجاه هذا المربض الحيوي
بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي هذه العمليه
الثالثه التي يعلن عنها حزب الله بعد
استهداف سكنه زف بين بالصواريخ التي اطلق
باتجاهها عدد من الصواريخ مما ادى الى
اصابتها واصابه تجمع للجنود وفقا لبيان
اعلنه كما هاجم اجهزه تجسسيه في موقع
راميا في جنوب لبنان ايضا تزمن كل ذك مع
هجمات اسرائيليه بالطيران الحربي ولحظ ان
نسبه هذه الهجمات تزايدت هذا اليوم وتركزت
في منطقه واحده هي الخيام خمس غارات
اسرائيليه استهدفت هذه البلده والتي تعد
اكبر بلدات القطاع الشرقي في جنوب لبنان
خمس غارات اطلقت في خلالها صواريخ على
منازل ادت الى تدميرها والى الحاق اضرار
بمنازل اخرى في هذه البلده و كانت مصيره
ايضا اسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا سكنيا ادى
ذلك الى استشهاد مواطن وجرح اثنين اخرين
وفقا ل الدفاع المدني اللبناني الذي هرع
الى المنطقه واجلى الجرحى بعد الهجوم بهذه
المسيره المدفعيه الاسرائيليه كذلك اليوم
شاركت بقصف مناطق مختلفه من جنوب لبنان
بشكل متقطع اخرها كان في طير حرفا اذ
اطلقت هذه اطلقت هذه المدفعيه عدد من الق
ذائف باتجاه احياء او اطراف هذه البلده
بالاضافه الى مناطق اخرى من جنوب لبنان
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه لم تفارق
الاجواء اللبنانيه هذا اليوم وحلقت بكثافه
فوق مناطق مختلفه خارقه جدار الصوت فيما
يعرف بالغارات الوهميه التي تؤثر عمليا في
السكان بسبب صوتها القوي الذي يحدث دوي
انفجارات هائله في اجواء المناطق التي
تعبر في خلالها واطلقت كذلك البالونات
الحراريه في محاوله لتجنب اي من صواريخ
حزب الله في حال
اطلاقها تبقى دائما معنا في المتابعه
ايهاب نذهب الى حسان مسعود وقبل ان نتحدث
معك ننوه لهذا الخبر العاجل الذي ننقله
على شاشه الجزيره نقلا عن حزب الله لبناني
يقول انه قصفنا كما يقول قاعده خربه ماعر
بصاروخ فلق واحد وحققنا اصابه مباشره اذهب
الى حسان ومعك نتابع ربما يقوله الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن التطورات على الجبهه
الشماليه لاسرائيل
الجيش الاسرائيلي وان كان مقلا في
تصريحاته حول هذه الجبهه فانه كان قد افاد
بتنفيذ طائراته الحربيه هجمات وغارات
باتجاه بلده او منطقه مروحين في جنوب
لبنان اي عبر هذه الغارات قال انه استهدف
مقرا عسكريا لحزب الله وادى الى تدميره
ونشر مقطعا للفيديو يظهر لحظه استهداف هذا
المبنى وهذا اتى بالتزامن مع رصدنا طيله
هذا اليوم تحليقا مكثفا بشكل واضح واكثر
مما كنا نتابعه خلال الايام الماضيه
للطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في سماء هذه
المنطقه الجليل الاعلى وتتجه نحو جنوب
لبنان وخلال
هذه غارات كنا نسمع دويه الانفجارات من
الجانب الاخر من داخل الحدود اللبنانيه
هذا اتى ايضا بالتزامن مع رصدنا ل عده
ضربات
بالمدفعيه خلال هذا اليوم من مناطق مختلفه
سواء كان من الجليل الاعلى باتجاه المناطق
الواقعه عند الحدود داخل الاراضي
اللبنانيه او حتى من المنطقه الواقعه في
الجليل الاعلى باتجاه القطاع الاوسط في
داخل لبنان وهذا اتى بعدما اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا عن رصده لاطلاق صواريخ تم
في كل من منطقه مزارع شبعه في اصبع الجليل
وتوله في الجليل الاعلى ودون ان يتحدث عن
طبيعه هذه الاهداف وعن نتائج ايضا هذه
الاهداف تحدث عن سقوط عدد من الصواريخ في
مناطق مفتوحه كما قال وايضا اكد على رد
مدفعيه الجيش الاسرائيلي على مصادر
النيران هذا ياتي ايضا بالتزامن مع الحديث
عن استمرار الجهود السياسيه الدوليه لتوصل
الى حل للتهدئه على الجبهه الشماليه بعد
الانتهاء من وقف اطلاق النار وان كان
مؤقتا في غزه وياتي ذلك ايضا على لسان عدد
من المسؤولين الذين ادلوا بتصريحات لموقع
وال الاسرائيلي نعم شكرا لكم حسن مسعود من
جليل الاعلى شكر موصول ايضا لايهاب العقدي
كان معنا من جنوب لبنان